checkpoint'teyiz arkadaşlar su mineral
asit baz ve tuzlardan bahsettik
mineraller solunumda enerji vermezler
dedik düzenleyicidirler ama bazıları
toksik zehir etkisi yaratır dedik
düzenleyici ifadesini kullanırken enzim
ve hormonu pozitif yönde etkileyen
maddelere düzenleyici diyebilirsiniz
size soru çözdürür dedim ve
sindirilmezler kendilerine özel iyon
kanallarından hücreye alınırlar yani bir
fosforibit katmandan tabakadan
geçmelerini beklemeyiz kalsiyumun
magnezyumun sodyumun potasyumun kendine
özel kanalları olacak bu yapılara
baktığımızda her birinin eksikliği bir
metabolik sıkıntıya neden olacak çünkü
bunlar enzimlerin kofaktörü olabiliyor
yani kendilerine özgü tepkimelerin
yardımcı grupları ya da işleyişinde ana
madde olabiliyorlar bunu enzime
bırakıyorum dolayısıyla bir mineralin
eksikliği bir başka mineralle
giderilemiyor dedik demir eksikliğinde
anemi kalsiyum eksikliğinde kasılmasında
kemik gelişiminde kanın pıtlaşmasında ya
da nörotransmitterlerin egzozitozunda
problem olur dedik hocam nörotransmitter
egzozitozu biraz ağır değil mi
görevlerinden biri sinir sisteminde bunu
tekrar edeceğiz şimdilik bir kere duymuş
olsam bana yeter magnezyum klorfilin
yapısına katılır ama insan vücudunda çok
fazla görevi var dedik kükürtten
bahsettik kükürt metyon aminoasidin
yapısına katılır kobalt B12 vitamin
yapısına katılır ki B12'nin adı o yüzden
kobal amindir dedik kalsiyum magnezyum
fosfor kemiklerin flor dişlerin yapısına
katılır azot fosfor ATP'nin DNA'nın
RNA'nın yapısına katılır dedik ve bu
maddelerin ne kadar hayati olduğuna
dikkat çektik suya geldim su kanımızın
%90'ı su plazma çünkü böyle bir oranda
su içeriyor hocam su güzel bir
taşıyıcıdır hani polar poları apolar
apoları çözer diyoruz ya su polar bir
molekül yani yüklü bir molekül
dolayısıyla birçok maddeyi çok rahat bir
şekilde kanımızda taşıyabiliyoruz ve bir
maddeyi suda çözmek demek ondan rahat
bir şekilde vücudumuzdan kurtulacağız
anlamına geliyor yani bir yerden bir
yere taşıyabiliriz öz ısı ve buharlaşma
ısına dikkat edelim öz ısı geç ısınır
geç sor muhabbeti buharlaşma terleme
soğutma muhabbeti ile ilişkilendirilmiş
okul kitabımızda diye belirttik
enzimlerin çalışması için uygun bir
ortam enzimler belli su
konsantrasyonlarından sonra çalışır işte
o yüzden biz meyve sebze gibi besinleri
kuruttuğumuzda uzun yıllar onu
koruyabiliyoruz çünkü üzerinde
mikroorganizmalar su olmadığı için
çoğalamıyor su enerji vermiyor mineral
gibi su yapısaldır arkadaşlar
vücudumuzun %70'i sudan oluşuyor bu
vurguyu da yaptık suyun katısı sıvısında
yüzüyor neden önemli hocam çünkü bir
buzul çağı atlattık yani su eğer dipten
donsaydı yani katısı sıvıda batsaydı o
zaman okyanuslarda göllerde nehirlerde
akarsularda denizlerde canlılık
kalmayacaktı çünkü dipten donduğunda
içindeki canlılarda ölecekti ama
yüzeyden donuyor bu da bir yandan ısı
yalıtımı sağlamış oluyor dedik
hidrolizde suyun öneminden bahsettik su
hidroksil ve hidrojen olarak iyonlarına
ayrıştığında maddelerin eksik gruplarını
tamamlıyor ve ortadan bağın kalkmasını
sağlıyordu fotolizden bahsettik
fotosentez sırasında su kullanan
canlılar elektron proton ve oksijenine
kadar enzimatik bir tepkimeyle suyu
parçalar ve açığa oksijen çıkartır
atmosferin oluşumunu sağlayan temel
maddeden bahsetmiş olduk kohezyon ve
adhezyon kuvveti su molekülünün
birbirini çekmesi kohezyon suyun başka
bir moleküle yapışması adhezyon hocam
cama bir su damlası yapıştı yapışma
adhezyon peki hocam o su damlasının
şekli ne kohezyon çünkü orada su
molekülleri birbirini çekti böcek suyun
üzerinde yürüyormuş o kohezyon kuvveti
sayesinde oluşan yüzey geriliminden
dolayı öyle olur hocam dünyanın en uzun
ağaçlığı topraktan nasıl zorlanmadan su
çekebiliyor en önemli kuvvet terleme
kohezyon kuvveti dedim ve burayı da
bitirdim geldim asit baz tuza asitler ve
bazlar tamamı inorganik miydi hayır
hocam bazıları organik bazıları
inorganik asitler hidrojen iyonu veriyor
tatları ekşi limondan aklınızda kalsın
limon asidi askorbik asit vesaire
bazlarla tepkime verebiliyor ve turnusol
kağıdını kırmızıya çeviriyor bazlara
baktığımızda çözeltisine genellikle
hidroksil iyonu veriyor asitlerle
tepkime verebiliyor tuzları oluşturuyor
turnusol kağıdını mavi mora çeviriyor
işte baba mor artır diye kodluyorsunuz
biliyorum ve kaygandır arkadaşlar
deterjan sabun yapımında bazlar
kullanılıyor ph power of hidrojen
hidrojen iyon konsantrasyonun gücü
aslında ve bir ortamla başka bir ortamın
pH gücü kıyaslandığında 2 4 3 6 4 8
bunları gördüğünüzde 10 üzeri -4 10
üzeri -8 şeklinde yazmanız lazım çünkü -
log h pH olacak bunu unutmayın dediğim
gibi okul kitabımız çok tatlı bir
örnekle bunu anlatmış ve son olarak
tampondan bahsedip sorulara bakalım
tampon bir ortamın aniden pH'ının
değişmesini engelleyen özel
moleküllerdir dedim ve sorulara
geçiyorum aşağıdaki tabloda bazı
mineraller verilmiş buna göre görev
eşleştirilmesi yapıldığında
aşağıdakilerden hangisinin açıkta
kalması beklenir sinirsel yetimde rol
alan mesela sodyum potasyum pompası
duyacaksınız sinir sisteminde kalsiyum
az önce nörotransmiter madde dedik iki
tane olabilir hocam nükleik asit hücre
zarı ve ATP'nin yapısına katılır fosfat
olabilir mi olabilir hemoglobinin
yapısında oksijen taşıyan demirdir
bitkilerde ışığı soğuran klorofilin
yapısına katılır magnezyum hocam
magnezyumu işaretledim bu da var kanın
pıtlaşmasında görev alır kalsiyum burada
iki görev sıkıntı yok hemoglobinin
yapısında demir var demirin eksikliğinde
anemi olur dedik dikkat edelim bazı
maddelerin pH değerleri verilmiş buna
göre ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur
limondaki hidrojen iyonu derişimi
kahveden daha fazladır bakıyorum limon
daha asidik kahveden doğru ph değeri
7'den küçük olan besinler ekşi asidik
7'den büyük olan besinler tatlı hocam
tatlı değil de acıdır ama bu acı biber
acısı değil arkadaşlar temizlik
maddelerinin pH değeri 7'den yüksektir
ve ele kayganlık hissi verir evet hocam
çamaşır suyu cevabımız 1 ve 3 olur
doğada bulunan inorganik maddelerin
canlılık için çok sayıda görevleri
bulunmaktadır bunlardan bazıları
hormonların yapısına katılma hücre
zarının ana iskeletini oluşturma bileşik
enzimlere kofaktör olarak katılmadır bu
parçada inorganik maddelerin
görevlerinden hangilerine
değinilmemiştir arkadaşım bak diyor ki
iskeleti oluşturuyor yapıya katılıyor ya
da gidiyor mesela hormonların yapısına
katılıyor hormonları etkiliyor
düzenleyici oluyor ancak solunumda
enerji vermezler hocam böyle bir şey yok
bir su damlasının damlamadan önceki son
anına kadar çeşmeye tutunmasını sağlayan
kuvvet yani yapışma adhezyon kuvveti
hadi yapışma demişim burada onu da
alıyorum peki damlanın kendine özgü
şeklinin oluşmasını sağlayan kuvvet
nedir kohezyon kuvvetidir ve bu kuvvetin
oluşmasında
hidrojen bağı en etkilidir tertemiz
neden çünkü su molekülleri arasında bu
şekilde bir çekim kuvveti var birinin
hidrojeni diğerinin oksijeni
su ile ilgili bazı sorulara yer verilmiş
soruların cevapları karışık olarak şu
şekildedir buna göre numaralanmış
sorulara cevaplar eşleştirildiğinde
verilen sorulardan hangisi açıkta kalır
enzimler için önemi nedir hocam enzimler
için metabolik ortam yaratır göl
çevresinin ılıman olması suyun hangi
özelliği ile ilişkilidir yüksek özgür
ısıya sahip olması böceklerin su
üzerinde durabilmesi suyun hangi
özelliğiyle sağlanır kohezyon kuvvetinin
oluşması buzul çağlarında sudaki
canlılığın son bulmamasını suyun hangi
özelliğine bağlayabiliriz katısı
sıvısında yüzüyor hocam fotosentez
tepkimelerinde oksijen nasıl açığa çıkar
fotolizle fotolizde su enzimlerin
yardımı ve ışığın etkisiyle elektron
proton oksijene ayrılır bir nevi
elektroliz olayı aslında ve açığa
oksijen çıkar hocam 5'e yer vermemişiz
minerallerden öncelikle hangilerinin
eksikliğinde kişide sırasıyla anemi
guater ve bağışıklık sisteminde
zayıflama görülür tabii ki hocam bir
sürü mineral bunlarla ilişkili olabilir
ama yani şimdi guater dediğimde iyot
gelecek aklıma anemi dediğimde önce
demir gelecek bağışıklık sistemi elbette
ki çok fazla şey var ama çinko gibi
selenyum gibi yapılar gelecek e
bakıyorum demir iyot çinko asit ve
bazlarla ilgili ifadelerden hangisi
yanlıştır bazı bazlar ortama hidroksit
iyonu vermeyebilir mesela amonyak asit
ve bazlar nötrleşme tepkimesi
gerçekleştirebilir yani her asit baz
tepkimesi nötrleşme değil çünkü
asitlerin tatları ekşidir bazlar
turnusol kağıdını mavi mora çevirir ph3
pH6'dan 2 kat daha asidiktir nasıl
hesaplıyordum bunu 10 üzeri -3/ 10 üzeri
-6 hocam 10 üzeri 3'ten 1000 kat demesi
lazımdı
bazı bileşiklerin kapalı formülleri şu
şekilde buna göre verilen bileşiklerin
yapılarına göre sınıflandırılması
aşağıdaki seçeneklerden hangisinde doğru
olarak verilmiştir su inorganik karbon
hidrojen oksijenden oluşmuş c5h104
ileride göreceksin ama şimdilik ben buna
organik diyorum bu bir deoksiriboz
c2h5oh etilalkol organik amonyak
inorganik üre ama organiktir bakın üreyi
çizeceğim mesela ben ileride size şu
şekilde yapıyı göstereceğim bakın üre
organiktir ama amonyak inorganik 1 ile 4
inorganik 2 ile 3 organik yukarıdaki
ifadeler eşleştirildiğinde aşağıdaki
maddelerden hangisinin açıkta kalması
beklenir kas sisteminin çalışmasında
görevli aslında hocam kalsiyum magnezyum
kasların kasılmasında iş yapıyor hatta
gece kramplarının 40 yaşından sonra
artmasının sebebi genelde magnezyum
eksikliğidir genelde bu bir tıbbi sonuç
yorum değildir arkadaşlar mide öz
suyunun üretiminde görev alır klor
hidroklorik asit kanın pıhtlaşma
tepkimelerinde görev alır kalsiyum kanın
ozmotik basıncı için öncelikli ve
önemlidir sodyum peki bakıyorum sodyum
var kalsiyum var klor var magnezyum var
kurşun nedir hocam kurşun ağır metal bu
toksiktir bu zehirdir bu beni
öldürebilir hatta geçtim insanda mide öz
suyunun pH'ı yaklaşık 2 idrarın normal
pHı 48 arasında değişmekle birlikte
ortalama 6 olduğu söylenir buna göre
mide öz suyu ile ortalama bir idrar pH'ı
karşılaştırılacak olursa yorumlarından
hangileri yapılabilir mide öz suyundaki
hidrojen iyonu derişimi idrara göre çok
daha fazladır mide öz suyunda bazik
ortamda çalışan enzimler daha hızlı
değil daha yavaş çalışır çünkü bazik
ortam demek pH7'den yüksek demek ama
mide öz suyu asidik insan vücudunda
farklı pH'lı sıvılar bulunabilir doğru
bir ifade cevabımız 1 ve 3 olur
minerallerden hangisi canlar için en
önemli enerji verici molekülün yapısına
katılır şimdi en önemli enerji verici
molekül ATP a tepeye baktığınızda evet
azotlu organik baz bir 5 karbonlu şeker
olan riboz bir de ne var bakın fosfat
var hatta adenin riboz fosfat fosfat
fosfat şeklinde burada fosforu
işaretlersin
mineraller insan sağlığı için çok önemli
olan moleküller bu nedenle gerekli olan
mineraller besinlerle mutlaka alınmalı
ve ne dedik mineralleri bir canlı
üretemez işte hocam ototrofıma
fotosentez kemosentez yapıyor o üretemez
mi üretemez bitki demir üretemez
magnezyum üretemez toprağa ekiyoruz
değil mi niye toprağa ekiyoruz işte suda
çözülmüş mineralleri alsın diye aşağıda
bazı mineraller ve eksikliklerinde
görülen hastalıklar karışık olarak
verilmiş bu mineraller ve
eksikliklerinde görülen hastalıklar
hangisinde doğru eşleştirilmiştir guatır
iyot kemik erimesi kalsiyum kansızlığa
baktım önce demir dişlerde çürüme flor
şeklinde gruplandırılabilir yani C B A D
cevabımız C seçeneği olur sırada doğru
yanlış sorularımız var mineraller
solunumda enerji verici olarak
kullanılmazlar su açığa çıkartan tüm
tepkimeler dehidrasyondur dehidrasyon ve
hidrolizi özellikle organik bileşikler
içerisinde anlatım yaptığım sırada bir
daha tepkime yazarak anlatacağım dedim
ama tüm su çıkartan tepkimeler
dehidrasyon değildir hocam bak solunum
sonucunda da su açığa çıkar inorganik
maddelerin yapısında karbon bulunmaz
ifadesi yanlıştır bazı inorganik
bileşiklerde olabilir su buharlaşma
ısısı düşük olduğu için etkili bir
soğuma sağlar düşük olduğu için değil
yüksek olduğu için tüm asit bazlar
inorganiktir hayır hocam bazıları
organiktir koohezyon kuvveti yüzey
gerilimi ile ilişkilidir doğru tüm
mineral çeşitleri insanda düzenleyicidir
hayır hocam bazıları zehir etkisi
gösterir öldürebilir klorofilin
yapısında bulunan mineral magnezyumdur c
H O N ve Mg doğru demir klorofili
sentezleyen enzimin kofaktörüydü tüm
canlılar mineralleri doğadan hazır alır
evet bir canlının ototrof olması onu
üretebileceği anlamına gelmezdi tampon
çözeltiler bir ortamın aniden asit ya da
baz olmasını sağlar değil önler demem
lazımdı ph2 8'den 4 kat daha asidik
değil 10 üzeri -2/ 10 üzeri -8 10 üzeri
6 kat hocam suyun başka bir maddeye
yapışması adezyondur atmosferin temel
oksijen kaynağı sudur çünkü su molekülü
fotolizde elektron proton ve oksijene
ayrılır anemi demir eksikliğinden
kaynaklanırken guatır iyot eksikliğinde
olur minerallerin vücutta fazla olması
bir problem yaratmaz her şeyin fazlası
zarardır arkadaşlar demirin aşırı
birikmesi karaciğerde çok ciddi
problemlere neden olabilir suyun özgür
ısısının yüksek olması ılıman iklimi
yaratır organizmalarda en fazla bulunan
inorganik madde sudur arkadaşlar
potasyum kalp ritmi için önemlidir ancak
fazlası ölümcüldür şimdi sodyum potasyum
pompası diye bir şey var arkadaşlar
sodyum potasyum pompası sinir
hücrelerimizin çalışması için önemli bir
durum ancak bir insanın kanında
kontrolsüz bir şekilde potasyum artarsa
kalbi durur kalp diyastolde kalır yani
kasılamaz o yüzden bir insanın damarına
doğrudan potasyum vermeyiz eğer bir
hastamızın potasyuma ihtiyacı varsa bir
serum fizyolojik bir çözelti içerisinde
yavaş ve kontrollü bir şekilde
göndeririz bir insanın kanına doğrudan
potasyum verilmez arkadaşlar kişiyi
öldürebilir insan kanının ideal pH'ı
7.4'tür tüm bazlar suda çözünürken
ortama hidroksil iyonu vermiyor bazıları
hidrojen alarak baz özelliği gösteriyor
dedim ve bitirdim umarım anlaşılmıştır